oh hello everyone I'm well how are you
how's it going so far
great well a lot of stuff there's a lot
of stuff okay great I'd love to go
around introduce yourself where you're
from and what you do and then we'll go
back around and do QA and I would make
that very selfish because that's you
know you get consumed pretty plenty of
macro free advice for me but like I'd
love to make sure I deliver on what your
singular question is here so let's go
this portion is like with me so I think
this is one you need to get selfish like
you'd ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is no like you
go fast this is the television is the
radio right now understood through a Reb
share with them model or through a V
model okay understand awesome so my name
is Doug Williams so I'm the founder
graphic drink and basically I'm a
personal CTO so I help solar
entrepreneurs small businesses and
they're struggling and trying to scale
and they're frustrated I go in and
basically build their tech stacks or
help them with automation that makes a
lot of sense what are you based
DC awesome yeah pretty cool and then
start with copper a so that's how it
started with you know years
interesting okay Bryan meal CEO of blind
zebra enterprises and sales training
sales coaching keynote speaking in
podcasting my site hustles on an NFL rep
is that true that's true I got your
present - I'm fired up about it already
I wanted already with the president no
we'll save for the end you NFL Ref yeah
you actually referee NFL gear society I
think it's amazing five years
you see that's crazy that's amazing
right how many games here do you do
22:15 regular season four preseason
hopefully I'm so fired up I cannot wait
to be bad at a call that you make next
year listen I already know the answers
it's human beings you know it's like
it's amazing cool that's really cool
let's rock n roll so in the Macra like
actually I'll just start with this
giving you three I would assume which
would be smart given what you're at
creative end media your on your path to
building on a van or media like agency
and trying to figure me nob viously
there's always nuances but creative and
media under one house and you're trying
to whatever it may be there may be a
different bunch of the Pink's comment
about asking about how you apply
retainer model to a software development
agency mm-hm
and so that's that's like primary is
solving this so we have we have a
software development agency that sits
next to a digital marketing agency so
they're all from the digital marketing
agency side we also have full-service
software though in terms of I mean
enterprise level stuff so all under what
one cooked one one company like one P&L
okay and it started with that and this
has been built on top that's correct
okay yeah so software development goes
back about four and a half years how did
that start me solo yeah pretty much
cool yeah
and then now so how many people are in
each so almost a bench of about 70
engineers on the right side with meaning
none full-time and all outsource when
you say bench so I invested in an agency
in st. Louis so that we could share an
engineer bench interesting so so they're
their full-time employees their
full-time of of them and then we get to
I get to lean into their bench and kind
of cost share I get it yeah easy
first of all capacity keeps my overhead
low totally understand yeah so so that's
that how many how many if any full-time
Deb's full-time Deb's yeah just over a
dozen understood and then kind of on
this side yes full-time and the agency
and how many of those about a dozen as
well just ten to ten fifteen yeah cool
yeah so on the software side I'm curious
if you've seen models work where you can
have a retainer that's more than just
support or maintenance right because
you've talked about breaking out the
strategy into its own component of how
you build a client or like the answer is
you can and that you've gone through
some of these things it's hard for it
not to be support or maintenance because
people bought into the value of that
right you know when I started
vaynermedia this company started as a
community management only that was the
only thing we did you know Campbell's
hired us and Oh some of your youngsters
but old Facebook like if you left
somebody on somebody's page that was
what was on the top of the wall it's
like MySpace you know like so you know
people weren't like the amount of people
that laughed me out of the room to make
comments to like do community management
and make content which is the core
foundation of like Who I am and like
what is probably considered
best-in-class
2019 marketing on digital right now put
out content on social networks and
engage with the community for insights
and right laughs go out of the room for
five thousand dollars a month laughed
out of the room with with a million
followers on Twitter when I knew him
when built-up Wine Library with like
been on Conan with like the kid the same
kid that built from three to 60 million
why I'm telling you that is it's the
answer the answer is of course if you
deliver on what you're asking for in
return and I believe there are a lot of
people emerging potentially in the mid
market that can afford to pay a strategy
around tech infrastructure this I think
both of you can easily convince a human
and say hey Gary you have Wine Library
let's go back to my dad's own store and
say you're wasting money on legacy tech
and bad infrastructural decisions by
just paying me three thousand dollars a
month where I will both be in the
backbone business so before you decide
if it's MailChimp or cloud this or
google-like or a new POV you're just I'm
backbone and on top of that I'll be
proactive and and set up off the Albion
defense Batphone but a quarterly we have
an in face or an 30 minute call every
two months or I'll be on offense where
me and my team are thinking about your
liquor store business and you you know
you build an infrastructure that allows
people to see what's going on best in
class in Canada the Canada Liquor
Control Board now puts QR codes on their
bottles I do believe that there's a
sector that would pay for thinking
because the the way you always get
people to understand it is the money
saved one of the ways I started breaking
through to community management was
saying how much do you spend on call
centers Oh
fucking-a Millions I'm like they blow
and they do nothing
community management when somebody goes
on your Campbell's page and says your
soup stinks that's also could be a call
center and we're only 60,000 for a year
and I'm gonna be got it so it's the
angle yes it's like the product or the
story that you present I gave it to you
I think that's the truth I mean I'm sure
there's others but I gave you the one
that like what like I'm always reverse
engineer from the consumer what would I
would say what would trick me and trick
in a good way
what would what would get me thinking
like hmm and you know one thing you
could do is like in the way if you go
prospecting it's like do you spend
$50,000 on technology technology is your
service your sir like you throw a lot in
there and all of us like my dad's
company why library right now is
incapable of making smart tech decision
that's not sure I forgot we have john
kano we are but but but but a lot aren't
and more importantly bless you and john
would know what to do with that too so
look people don't like to pay for
thinking they don't like it
strategies mmm but great because there's
an output along with it yeah strategy
baked into videos cool strategy just for
the sake of strategy not cool got it
yeah notice how i made you put something
tangible in there i'm gonna give you a
30 minute call every night you know
see so people want some you know
something I'll be honest with you one of
the ways to do it is to do an annual
conference yeah one of things we're
about to do at Boehner Sports just to
give you a preview you'll see me
promoting in six months I gotta get it
past AJ but I think I got it we have a
lot of people that are doing brand deals
with our players so much of it has to do
with me and they're trying to like quit
and I'm like look why don't we just if
they do brand deals what our partners
like with our players why don't we do a
thing every year like the Saturday you
know the Saturday before the Superbowl
in whatever town it is and they get
access to that one day full of it no
money to spend time with me and there's
an hour like you know what we did in
Atlanta is exactly how I'm thinking
about it Atlanta that was the [ __ ]
cool party and I'll do that again in
Miami we'll have 2 Chainz and well you
know we'll kill it and it'll be culture
that's Saturday night Friday will be the
business conference for the people that
sign thousand dollar deal or more with
banner sports people and what those
businesses are gonna do and be like [ __ ]
it I don't give a [ __ ] who Vayner Sports
gives to what players my money for my
cheese puffs I just want to be with Gary
for that day on Friday I would pay got
it that's I have to think reverse
engineered them
marketing agency yes really generally
wanted this year
amazing congrats Thanks so it's more of
starting well for us yeah versus coming
to you in two years going [ __ ] I wasted
hours on this and dollars on that that's
right that's exactly right you can go
back to where you were if you even were
ever in between ten and twenty
full-timers mark yeah we were and I
started my company in a conference room
of another company like we were like
people like kind of continue to forget
that when you zero like a thirty friends
or got no respect
we were we were small for a long time
because the first two years I was pretty
passive I mean I think when I took over
two-and-a-half years in I think we were
less than 30 yeah we like we got crazy
when I started running it full-time
I just love hiring people that's not a
joke so good yeah yeah I mean a couple
core things disproportionate over
communication with every single person
that's in it like the game-changing
reason why vaynermedia is still
foundationally strong is how close I was
to the first hundred employees it still
permeates Hill we were its head later of
like old vein or new like there's many
things that will come from it later but
it is the number honestly it's raising a
child over love the [ __ ] out of your kid
in the first four years and see
ridiculous dividends later like you know
later you can worry about entitlement
but at four they can't be entitled just
love the [ __ ] out of them later you can
like not let them win like I do now you
know
but in the beginning but and they'll cry
does every day but but because they're
getting used to like what is this I'm
some you know but over so it's your are
you you're the guy you you have to build
a real relationship with all of them
thanks for the post-processing it's
really you have to build a real
relationship and and you have to manage
all of them differently you have to
manage them based on them not based on
your and you sometimes they want and at
first everyone wants there's a million
things spirit at 12 and 20 like you're
gonna have that awesome culture like you
know people who stay later you're close
[ __ ] cut out the cancer quick if you buy
accent [ __ ] up and hired somebody you
got to get you know give her or him real
rap the only time I'm pretty radical
candor is when they're a singular cancer
in a small group where I'm like hey like
nobody likes you
well I'm the best employee I'm like cool
I'm still gonna fire you that the best
employee isn't the one who makes the
most money or the client likes the best
it's the holistic best and all eleven
people in this office don't love the way
you're rolling so that's important early
cancer is important because it keeps
like positive vibes it's a very nurse I
think I think the first four years of
company are disproportionally nurturing
you know it's a it's actually really
funny I there was a period in 2011-12
when I was investing in pretty heavily
in female centric startups
you know Birchbox and Micmac all these
companies and you know later it became
such a part of our culture like you know
there was a moment twenty four months
ago we're like what's your portfolio you
look like with female founders and I
could see was bubbling up and I remember
thinking like this is gonna be awesome
because I was really in a good place but
it was really funny I was in a good
place not by being a nobleman or like
trying to be fair it was out of my
general thesis of the other way it was
my disrespect it was my it was me being
what's the word I'm looking for it well
no because sorry I used the word because
I it was me being I was stereotyping men
even though I'm a nurturing dude I was
stereotyping men for not being I was
being very very basic women are you know
but I actually believe it I believe that
over nurturing emotionally a business in
the first three to four years is
remarkably underrated all feelings all
kumbaya I mean you got to pay the bills
you got to get through but I think
that's where if you can help in I don't
know you well enough if you can put a
lot of the financial onus on yourself
and you know right it's very cliche
that's why I asked you did you start at
first I'm like good he's gonna be able
to do this because he was a like when
you're the person that is the thing at
first you know it like that's the beat
you can't imagine how fun it is to walk
through this company
knowing that me as the CEO is the best
practitioner of social media work there
is no executive that I'm scared of in my
own company it's very powerful most
executives lose touch with reality or
never had in the first place they just
like thought of a business idea like
their partner was the one that made the
bread you know so as much onus and
pressure on you to allow to establish
that culture and then where I missed the
mark was in year five success when you
were here when we first move in here 3 3
right 3 it's the REA 3 will be in August
right yeah yeah so what are we in 1916 I
took him five years in I I did its so I
waited one year too long to make the
transition from over nurturing to merit
which that in creates entitlement and I
had a I had a very difficult time
unwinding that it took me a good year
and a half because I let go of 30 people
to make this statement rip the band-aid
that [ __ ] up every but I mean you
would have thought that like it was the
Great Depression here good people
yelling at me and an all-hands on in my
own employees they like [ __ ] you
but that you know that I made the
mistake I waited a year a year and a
half too long I make fun of entitlement
to let your kids win eighth place
trophies but I missed the mark here by a
year year and a half and the moment I
realized that I was like I just remember
going through that in my own mind I was
like this is gonna suck because what
entitled kids don't like is when you cut
off their credit card like like the kids
that you buy a Mercedes for in high
school pay for their college on Linum
uber unlimited equinox and the first
year out of college you buy them their
apartment and you get them unlimited
uber continuous and you got them their
job when you decide cuz you're a parent
that decides that for some weird reason
23 is the year a kid gets cut off that
kid [ __ ] shits on you like crazy
because you didn't condition them so so
that happened so I think I think if you
get your that to me is the
if you can get your timing right from
over coddling culture safety yes mm
heart and you can make that transition
to merit and every company is different
every leader is different you know I
missed the mark here which I thought
we'll hope will make me not miss the
mark the next time it's a but here's why
I do it I missed the mark and our
company has never been healthier today
overcorrecting from when you created too
much entitlement is a hell of a lot
better than establishing a company that
is a soulless financial machine
you're never injecting culture into that
so the seed matters coolant so in terms
of over communication so for the first
in college all the way till I exited my
first business I was pretty much solo
and so it doesn't come natural right try
to figure out your way maybe it may be
you know maybe it's phone calls maybe
it's hiring a chief heart officer like
making an investment to culture now and
giving her or him disproportionate power
yeah you know yeah cool how do you guys
manage your accounts because there's a
time when you're younger of different
company you have you know a an analyst
managing you know pretending ten
accounts right and then how do you go
about making that transition if you want
to one or two one
you know carefully and when you're
asking that are you asking financially
or like how the account gets used to it
or the people themselves like give me
the all of the above I think I think the
Aces answer with of a financial role and
pay more therefore they get you know
more people yes but more of like a part
of the company and culture because it's
two completely
different strokes you know I've worked
at other agencies so more I've managing
a ton of accounts so I mean some midsize
and then some bigger ones where I am
down this for one client only so but
I've never been in any transition from
one to another so I think that's what's
your concern in that transition I don't
know that's actually because there well
that's that's a good that's what's
really good about this question I think
it's a good theoretical question and I
think it's less scary in real life which
is why I asked that and which is why I'm
glad the way you answered I think you're
worried about the boogeyman you know
what I mean like I think you're worth I
think you're trying to be thoughtful
which is amazing it's what you want from
leaders to begin with so that's a good
tell but I think you know hey Karl
you're on seven accounts now you're on
four there's you know some people might
get like are you worried about the
internal par like the actual employees
that work for you like trip making that
transition yeah I think you're I think
it's a boogeyman thing really I do like
it's a it's a different mindset that
either that person can do or can't do
you're probably not gonna know if they
can't work it you know lots of bodies
you know what I mean I think people prep
for things a lot of times that there was
no preparation needed for think about
how much you psych yourself out for the
first time you're gonna kiss somebody
years for some years like you know like
some of these things are just
overthought it's casting - Carol is
gonna transition beautifully Rick not so
much
yeah Rick you know what I mean I think
for you on the financial side it's easy
because you're just allocating and then
it's just this is why culture matters
dude this is my culture [ __ ] matters
if you do part one anything that's scary
about part two the culture eats up and
fixes Carol who's struggling from going
from four to one because she's bored
he's gonna feel safe to talk about it
instead of looking for another job to
get challenged this place got too big
let me go somewhere where I can get that
high of 10
sir I'm going culture culture is like
oxygen people think it's like a
department people think you know it's
it's it's not like finance it's [ __ ]
a living and breathing thing
it is the operating system it is not one
of the apps finance is an app creative
is an app strategy is an app culture is
the [ __ ] operating system it's
probably the proudest thing I'm up to
it's one of the most proud I'm so proud
that what I'm putting into the business
ecosystem around this subject matter
because I'm an alpha guy it's not like
you know I'm not like you know an 88
year old grandma saying culture Matt you
know like I'm alpha but this is real and
I'm glad that it's like starting to pick
up a little momentum it's gonna really
pay out so that's why I think please
please it was because you know because
I've been in building both of those
roles just the depth of analysis and
quality of work that you're expected to
but the client is the son is the judge
in the jury of the quality of the work
right which is a variable bigger client
higher expectations potentially it's
casting the bigger client just might
have gone to same colleges you and likes
you and the decided your works better
play in real life that's what I do got
it
potentially the client is the judge in
the jury but they're a human like a
referee all I need to know about
referees is he's a human being it's
making a subjective call based on his
knowledge of what pass interference is
or isn't you understand it's an ideology
that you hope he does it right every
time you can't what angle desi these
guys are going so fast one of my biggest
things with referees is they need to get
into better shape like no but you know
I'm obviously I'm making a fun joke but
like it's [ __ ] hard out like I've so
I mean I'm very weird with reps I barely
ever get upset with with referees
because I'm like it's [ __ ] out you
know fast these [ __ ] are no
matter how smart he is about positioning
and he gonna fill
four days to be on the 36-yard line and
this hash these [ __ ] are moving and
so what you're mad at them because you
watched it a minute later in super
triple slow deal fastest [ __ ] is so the
same way think about refereeing is the
same way I think about clients it's
casting I have plenty of small clients
are way tougher and big clients just
playing people paying me eleven million
dollars they're passing this [ __ ] and
people pay me forty eight dollars and
pissed the [ __ ] the key is look the key
for your business is learning when to
fire a client which is foreign as [ __ ]
of course especially what am i late when
you're young and don't have the leverage
you don't fire kids always ask me Gary
what do I find like can you afford it no
then you don't fire you fire when you
could afford it you know you know things
are great in alia you should fire
clients that are bad to your employees
to keep up the culture it's the
operating system yes what if you fire
them and go out of business there is no
operating system you know
that kind of finding the line between
like you know building up and this my
time to the personal branding it never
inhabit the line between like putting
our work and our time into building our
brand and then how do you balance that
with light you know the work that is
driving revenue like your client work
okay you have to do both yeah it's hard
in the beginning but answer is both the
client is subjective so you got to be
thoughtful that you're not deciding how
much time and effort you have to put
into the work you can think of it I mean
look you're creative you know this you
can make something that takes you
thirteen minutes that they think is the
most remarkable thing they've ever seen
and you can do something that your
life's work and then you walk in there
like there's a piece of [ __ ] you're in
the complete subjective game so you have
to use the advantages of that while
recognizing the disadvantages of it
understand are you a perfectionist
because you're insecure and you spend
two more hours editing something because
of your own ideological nature of
perfection which could have been used to
work on your brand or are you not got it
yeah you know a lot of creatives don't
like to hear speed and output and
quantity matters and I'm sure it's a
friction of my own team of looking at D
like it's no like when people because
leave what four months now forty five
like when you first come in it's like
look like either I'm so respectful I
think creative is the variable of
success so it's really funny because I
don't look the part of like the champion
have created right but it really is what
I believe and it's and it was what I am
I also equally believe in output and
speed there's such a practical part to
me it's no different no I just said it's
up saying the same things over and over
both like if you break everything down
it's both it's always both the answer is
both
it's why we have a problem in this
country people think it's left or right
dancers both everyone for I can't
believe how much our our country now
believes it's one or the other it's
nuances of both the good new offices
it's just hard to you know from one so
anyway so dude the answer is both if
you're not building brand you're not
creating funnels that give you new
business in a way that's passive if
you're not delivering on the quality
work
you're not retaining it's like eating in
the old days you have to hunt and farm
the answer is both so like what does
that mean more hours or hire more people
like you know it's not super complicated
or the one that because those are tough
both being efficient with your actual
time when people come in here you mean
my employees are like I need some money
on this account I'm like I'm not giving
you somebody on that account and they're
mad that like you [ __ ] trying to burn
me out I'm like no you're on [ __ ]
read it for an hour a day
you know yep good
yep okay so ask the even bigger question
yes let's go ninety-eight percent of
people that work here still think that's
our biggest problem so let's talk about
that for a couple the reason I answer
you that way
ninety-eight percent of the people here
feel that I'm too far ahead if they even
the most people don't care about it but
like the people that are trying to help
this company like my direct reports and
like most of the feedback we had a new
head of comm we were hiring a new head
of comms I interviewed a lot of people
it was the number one thing they wanted
to talk about Gary's so excited if I get
this opportunity I'm so excited to like
you know build up the brand of Vayner so
it's not just now there's things that
come along with that you know if he
hates it too much or loves it too much
both of our problems so got it so I
don't know like the answer is you're
fine in theory more than you can imagine
but we're at the vulnerability of him as
a human and if he hates it too much it's
stressful he doesn't want to somebody
think of selfie or like clients call him
instead of the people you build around
or if he likes it too much and it
becomes a character ature of himself and
he gets high in their zone supply so
that that's the answer to that question
trying to do mistakenly is we think it's
a logical problem that we need a resolve
as he's the bottleneck of the company
but in actual fact of emotional core
where if it's not emotional about it he
is and the 1% is for one person because
I'm the branch people want many people
my strategy beside so that's where
you're making an operational mistake so
one thing I did not make an operational
list think about is nobody gets me and
never was a promised now if you'd you
know if Pepsi comes along and says well
we'd like you for these three like we
want you for like it's all negotiable
but it was never in play the end right
they made a decision that tell them
right to the face you do not get me I do
not work on any account I'm not here I'm
in the bad phone business that [ __ ]
better be backbone [ __ ] like the Joker's
[ __ ] choking someone not there's a
puddle in the street Batman you know
what I mean I'm in the Batman business
but okay where does she come from but
it's but it's like I like communicating
in that way because it makes it obvious
you know like even though it's funny and
ridiculous it's very clear of what I'm
telling you you want to call me because
your business in real trouble or like
you're super upset with the people
managing your business like we can have
that combo but I'm not gonna [ __ ]
review that tweet expectations up front
which takes humility from the person the
the thing that most people are unable to
say about me until they really get
closer is the humility part that comes
along with the confidence you know takes
humility of the personal brand
so my second question please and I
highly respect everyone because we've
got a scurvy and is wonderful enough to
talk about themselves in that position
because I'm good please it took us a
long time to get there thank you here's
what happened
wow that makes me super happy he used he
used our relationship okay yep yep yep
I'm telling you I mean it I mean it
Indian culture Russian culture is the
same [ __ ] obviously there's a couple
that out like but like stuff to prove
you one is how humans are wired go ahead
we bought a house yeah
if you see a stock account I'm going to
ever go back to data that was the time
when the first row happened
interesting I understand maybe maybe we
need to talk about that and so one day
when we had to pop them astray we popped
a little bit further down and two houses
down it's a massive mansion this is
about nine months later there was an
open house goodbye I'm gonna make sure
I'm following this you buy a house to
house is over nine months earlier right
I understood yep you you at that same
time are starting the business and it's
starting to work
I understand it's starting to work like
good things are happening in the
business you're starting to see the
early indications if something good is
happening so what you do with those
early indications is decide that you
should buy the bigger house that makes
it by the way that makes a ton of sense
to me keep going he's a dreamer I'm the
believer I'm like this house is three
times of what current house is if you
think we can do it let's do it we signed
the papers there two weeks later to buy
this house and
the same agent sell out house in their
life and look at us live account and
that was a second huge spike in growth
and sustained growth so it's not just
like yeah that might have had nothing to
do with the houses by the way that might
have dipped in I understand I understand
but like that the growth might have not
happened because you're under pressure
it might have been because you're right
about the thesis of what you were doing
good you want to make you something more
uncomfortable if you play a game let me
say one thing and I don't know if this
very going but I'm gonna jump in cuz I
like to do that if you're gonna play a
game of like every time we put ourselves
in macro pressure that we are at this
united front and we emotionally and
financially and strategically we have
big spikes of growth you're gonna pick
wrong one day and loot so don't make
that your thesis figure out how to
create pressure in a different way that
isn't financially ok I understand you've
grown into being able to afford it
easier I get it
understood ok
of course it makes sense but that might
not have anything to do with the
pressure I'm worried that you're
strapping it to something that might
have been serendipitous not the engine
of it may also not be as exciting
because the maturity of what you're
doing is now doing much of the same
whereas before it was learning and
finding new and doing there may be a lot
of reasons that it's not as exciting
unless you're just masochist of
financial like me and I'm not joking
maybe I can't you know I don't know you
well enough but like it's highly
unlikely that like that's the case but
wait a min you live your parents they
moved them into your house you mean so
you sold that big house I see
that's cool I understand maybe there are
just another thing and I'll let him
segue but another thing for you to
debate maybe you should start a new
business that's what I do
yeah I just keep starting new businesses
well and some will fail and some won't
but in the net I don't give a [ __ ] cuz
I'm happy starting a new business for me
makes me happy it makes me happy I'm not
really worried about it like I love when
everybody you know everybody around
straight men and women are like yeah I'm
like I want to be happy like you can
quit Boehner and start your own company
if you want to be safe
yeah I think I think that plays a lot of
closure for me because no way do I want
to yes I just I just knew that wasn't
the way you can pressure yourself and
challenge yourself without it being the
financial part it can be the
intellectual part like one of the
reasons I'd love to start businesses is
to see how right I am about something
because I love when people like oh I
thought of uber before Ober I'm like
that's great Johnny like what does that
mean like a lot of people talking about
[ __ ] oh I knew I knew snap stock was
gonna go like what does that even mean
I'm in the business of putting my mouth
my money where my mouth is maybe that's
what you're looking for
do you know what I mean for me just
because you like concentrating and me
that's amazing that's phenomenal I think
it's a great thesis I think it's an
incredible thesis that you should focus
on something and see at home how about
the fact that I got D's and F's for that
same macro rationale or you could be me
which is you love throwing up 47 plates
and you're comfortable if 16 collapse
because you like thirty-one plates more
than one
100% that's right
that's where honestly you just made me
so happy if if you can get into legacy
curiosity process over bank account I
don't think I've ever really known how
much money I've had ever I've no clue
right now
enough to be dangerous to make sure it's
enough to not be dead but like when your
process is the game in a much better
place you're welcome I understand cuz
the monetization against that versus a
hundred thousand that don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah and and the Pete and I oftentimes
like where it really becomes an
interesting debate for a lot of people
depending on how they're wired for
example I can get a lot of money for
coaching I don't want to so there's two
groups ones that can't and there's ones
that subconsciously actually don't want
to because an enormous percentage of
people that pay for coaching are paying
for the feeling that they're fixing
something versus actually trying to fix
it one of the reasons I really struggle
with a lot of people I know is they're
bottom-feeding on people and so you got
to figure out which group it's an
important question for you when you meet
somebody you're like hey you can do this
it's either that they can't fill the
pipe with valuable enough content or
actually they'd be more like me which is
interesting which is they just don't
feel good about it it's an important
part whereas I'm thrilled to sell a
hoodie or a sneaker or a glass of wine
it's also very important to analyze your
customer coaching is very tough when you
know the person is looking for a quick
fix in the majority 100,000% the end and
then what it does is takes people out of
their truth because their ROI is the
coaching business to help them actually
coaching supplements
recurring stuff so I put two questions
do you know it for us to do that I need
to get myself into the software space to
allow them a platform to build their
Drive
ok that's that's what I'm starting to
feel the 200 coaches that we have if
they can all have one white labeled
software that they use to deliver to
their tribe that can then open up the
door for them to pull for them to segue
in affiliate products no supplements
understand myself so right now who have
kind of got two empty gaps the first
enemy gap
is if you were us now you have 200
clients you had 20 million dollar gun
revenue sales how do you begin to enter
into software and tech knowing that
that's the future of fitness and that
that will help your clients grow and
they need they need software in tech and
then the second question is how do you
form strategic partnerships with other
products services for example the
supplement companies companies apparel
so that you bring it under one big
umbrella brand and use the software when
they build the tribe so that they don't
make so much money on the coaching but
everything else is so much so leading
with cool your prescription is to buy
these don't plan I understand you either
build a tech or you rent the tech or you
buy the tech the end yeah I mean I think
everyone's different you know you want
to feel more financial pressure take a
lot of the three million dollar you know
revenue business and deploy it against
buying something from maybe a company
that thought they were building and
consumer tech platform but they didn't
realize how [ __ ] hard that was and
they failed they've run out of money and
you can scoop up the tech the first
thing you probably have to do is bring
somebody that looks like these to
directly in your life as a partner or
somebody who actually gives a [ __ ] the
biggest mistake that people make when
they go into the tech business is they
try to outsource the CTO and it's
different than where he is going
I mean if you're gonna be in the tech
business and in essence you're gonna now
start selling a SAS product to all these
individuals
you better [ __ ] have somebody who
gives a [ __ ] for the next eight years at
your hip and a lot of times it's an
entrepreneur who knows nothing about and
they think gonna be clever and have
somebody build a SAS product and [ __ ]
Poland and then what happens when
there's a [ __ ] update and what
happens when something break like they
[ __ ] this up all the time what I would
do I'd probably probably give a 5% of
the company and hire a CTO and have her
and build it or or analyze the situation
say actually we don't need to build it
these three series of products in the
marketplace we add or one layer on
top of it we use their api's and we've
got a product and see what's really
interesting about this right so what's
interesting is like and these people
actually do it like what would and this
is actually just an insight for all of
you what's interesting about me and
probably what's manifest with me is I'm
dangerous enough to be able to give that
answer where people that actually know
are like [ __ ] it's a good answer right
that's what that's something that's just
good for everybody learn I back to all
the plates I think something that people
understand is how important it is to be
dangerous enough
and you better be dangerous enough in
technology and communication because
that's where our world's going until all
of us die those two things are here
you've been every dangerous enough in
understanding tech and you better be
dangerous enough in understanding how to
communicate which currently is social
media like that's probably a much bigger
factor in who I am right now then maybe
even I articulate enough I'm glad I just
did that because that really [ __ ]
matters because you do have to market
your business even if you're b2b and you
should know how to do LinkedIn marketing
because it will change your businesses
you you need you going to the SAS you
can't rent that [ __ ] you better be has
to be part of you so I listen one of the
weird you know I think the mistake a lot
of people would make four years ago is
you're gonna learn how to code like
everybody [ __ ] that was the unlock to
luck you know like like you know like
it's a commodity every kid like I
couldn't get I was so pumped five years
ago when everyone was sending their kid
to learn how to code I'm like this is
gonna be awesome
coding is gonna be like plumbing I'm
gonna be paying [ __ ] twenty six
thousand a year for everyone's like
you're gonna make two hundred fifty
thousand like do people understand basic
human supply and demand if everybody
learns how to code like the reason all
those kids that actually were nerds and
learned how to code and popped out in
two thousand three four five six seven
mattered is cuz that's what it was
coming and nobody has the skill and so
that's why they won every [ __ ] if
every eight-year-old learns how to
[ __ ] code right please
you know look bro honestly you [ __ ] this
is why I love this [ __ ] like you should
talk to these two they're probably know
people like there's a lot of ways to go
about this uh you know you can just you
can either talk to people that marc
wilso like you could these people
probably know I mean you're in Australia
they may not know like there's things to
talk about here you can decide to go
remote you could be like me and you want
to all the good book here or like
whatever you do but it's not as hard as
you think you know like one thing that
I've always like to do in the beginning
is you look at [ __ ] in the world that
you like and you literally do four hours
of google to find people that built it
you find out it's an agency that built
it here and then you reach out and you
look on the agency site and you
literally see head of product and you're
Karen Thompson and never to believe her
Twitter is linked to and you just DM
that her and say you're heron comes in
your [ __ ] app that you built for
honeybee was really rad and a great
product like I'm looking to hire a CTO
and she's like as a matter of fact our
head of you know development over here
just said to me yesterday that I'm on a
new job like I mean like you work you
reach out to them every one of them is
interested like you email info at
would you start you're right depends on
what you think depends of what you think
you're good at yeah you know if you
think you're good at the Tollbooth
business you build a tote booth if you
think you're good at the highway
business you build a highway that's what
the two things are that's what the two
things are if you want to sit in the
middle and somebody's building a meal
plan and you're sitting in the middle
and there's influencers and you sit in
the middle and you arbitrage that's what
you do
I think you that's the Tollbooth if you
think you're good enough to [ __ ] make
the meal plan that's the highway biggest
companies in the world right now are the
toll booths of the Internet Amazon Apple
swipe mark loves blockchain that
eliminates the toll booths got it that's
why I like personal brands and why I
wrote crashed into the pedestal that my
book crush' is gonna be put on in 30
years
is remarkably exciting for me personally
because what at scale what blockchain
does is justifies the behavior of people
building personal brand because it's the
only thing going to be left is the thing
and the audience on the other side there
will be many technologies built on like
the the thesis and I don't know how it
will evolve and I'm not dangerous enough
just yet to fully have even great thesis
on this but my lightweight thesis on
this in its super macro I'm very
confident which is there's the person
and the audience and a lot of ways
that's what the internet did with them
people layered on top of it which led to
the next innovation that's all you know
that's gonna feel like the network's
cool
so just two questions this kind of goes
into actually like you were just saying
like removing certain things so
originally I built an app for a sports
agent who wanted to put herself out of
business so basically it was an app that
acts like honey the same agenda m4v noir
sports put everybody had a business
limit go ahead and this one's like
basically its direct to the player can
sign their contracts with the branch so
smart
Oh Brandt from a marketing standpoint
understand he goes into escrow and then
when they either do yeah got it
I understand so done this going through
a copyrighted done stuff with his being
got to be with AJ for various sports and
it's awesome but the thing was I can do
things like that I can be a nice man I
can do this
now it goes into who we sometimes
represented right so we have one of the
clients of little skies and so he's on
tour and so I was a guy the partner I
have he has his own business but he's a
videographer so he does everything with
him so we did a documentary about him
his family everything but there's one
thing that when we're trying to get
bigger coverage with bigger life complex
things like that it seems like it's
moving targets like we can get smaller
outlets but there's always seems to the
decision-maker it's not that it's always
moving when we're trying to distribute
that kind of content what we do with
micro dollars for those well it's
because it's because they have the
leverage yeah it's a moving target
because it's a highly political decision
you want free distribution potentially
and aware attention is the asset if
complex or as we continue to build 137
p.m. if you're gonna hit me up me like
yo we made this awesome and sky's
[ __ ] on it right now matters and I'm
gonna have to say to myself like but I
don't want to your the contents of
commodity I'm like [ __ ] it
let's just go make our own tea grizzly
documentary like like you because we've
got the audience yeah yeah right and so
and content
is the variable and the most important
thing but the supply of content is
remarkable
there's 877 soundcloud rapper
documentaries being made right now
because everybody wants to be d-roc and
like there's a lot going on right so
like the you know that that's why it's
that's why that's happening because
they're trying to figure out they'd
rather do it themselves does that make
sense yeah and they're gonna continue to
go down that route everything's gonna be
fully integrated people gonna make and
distribute themselves you see where I'm
going you could still catch some stuff
because the decision-maker is just like
[ __ ] I love I [ __ ] with little skies
this was fresh but they don't want to
pay money for it and or or they don't
want to share the revenue when they get
a sponsor to layer on top of it this is
why I'm building it this way I think
about what I'm doing vaynermedia has the
relationship with the brand the
publishing company is the distribution
right the media part of vaynermedia is
enhanced distribution my production keep
it like you see what I'm doing yeah I
don't be the mercy of anybody almost
which is kind of unique when we're doing
these mini dots what we're trying to do
is actually just either give the rice or
something to whatever platform but use
that as leverage for other getting other
clients so we're not actually looking to
okay so when you say other clients
you're charging the artist well
absolutely a lot of them it depends on
which artists right makes sense
Drake not so much you know skies two
years ago may be exact I got it go and
so with guys the videographer we
actually are all from the same town like
from years ago so he documented skies
since he was seven that's how amazing
and his father almost died when he was
like 14 his the whole reasons us guys
start rapping was his father gotten a
horrible accident third-degree burns
everywhere it couldn't speak for a while
and he wrapped but he taught his kid and
everything in that
else guys that's insane so he has the
whole Domino's like he has all these
well that sounds like a unique piece of
content and that I would be more careful
with that sounds you know and this is
white content is the variable right like
a key you know like so as you added more
context that seems unique if you've got
footage of that [ __ ] yeah that's unique
to me I think that I wouldn't like I
would be more thoughtful about that to
me I think you need to try to reach out
to Hulu and Amazon and Netflix and try
to really go for the jugular yeah not
even like I think you you know to your
point lower places I don't think you
play in the complex vice-like high P
like I think you go [ __ ] jugular if
you've got that footage because the
footage is the value problem it's funny
it's making me think about something I
don't think people understand like
literally the most valuable asset that I
put in a trust for my kids is all the IP
footage of everything I'm recording yeah
it's wild right because I had no value
so the never the value on it when I put
it in a trust is like a hundred thousand
bucks so my intuition is if you actually
project the potential of VR fifty years
from today
somebody might you could have unlimited
people paying $19.99 to sit in that seat
right now and think they're in this room
I always use the analogy up would I
today pay and how much would I pay to
sit in the room of a meeting between
Bill Gates and Steve Jobs in 1984 for me
the way I learned a lot because I'm good
at contextual history so I pay the five
g's because I could afford it and
because I know if i sat there and
listened they would say something that I
could contextualize into 2019 that would
help me interesting right
dealing with all the things we were
talking about CTO and all the things but
the developed is basically it's called
being a full stack for any developer
yeah I understand me to make sure we're
populating that and what I'm focusing on
I have severe dyslexia and I think kids
need to learn how to basically learn
these skills because it's just not I was
terrible tool you it just doesn't work
the same way with that so I'm I'm
basically putting this together as a
program and I don't know curriculum yeah
and I don't know if is shouldn't be
feasible where I should even care about
a revenue stream or do that or just
worry about the program and try to teach
it as many as possible well that's a
personal question right like I think
that look all of us have different
levels of what they want to do selfishly
and what you want to do selflessly right
and so I never judged that I think
that's circumstantial right I chose the
route you know maybe because I had
options cuz I knew how to build
businesses otherwise to not monetize my
audience but I don't judge that I don't
judge that and I don't think anybody
should live to anybody else's standard
and maybe you start charging at first it
hits paydirt you did well and you're
like [ __ ] I've done well now and this
clearly is working let me make it free
for everybody in the world maybe you
start it maybe you go more my route you
make it free that builds up equity in
itself and it lets you monetize in other
places where you get to speak for like
there's a lot of ways to do this and I
don't think there's a right way there's
only a right way for you I hate when
people try to impose their way you know
I'm and I'm very passionate but I'm not
trying to impose my way because it's
[ __ ] free I'm trying to use it as a
context point and you can do whatever
you want with it I don't you know it's
something I'm trying to clarify more of
like I don't think I'm right I think I'm
right for me it's a data point and your
ability to synthesize that and
understand your own nuances is the key
you know who's right Tony Robbins or
Oprah they're different Oprah had a
luxury of a TV deal to not charge her
audience but that's what she did after
because that's you know I don't know I
don't know I don't like to I don't want
to have a mastermind I don't want to
have a core I don't
but I don't mind selling you sneakers
because my big thing there is if you're
wearing sneakers anyway you know so for
me it's comfortable I want to give away
my content and I do look at people that
sell their content more cynically I do
but that's ok it doesn't mean I'm right
and it does and it's and I and I
citizens is actually wrong it's not for
me you do you you can do either and they
both can work you can hold your breath
build equity on giving it away for free
and then do something on the other side
for yourself it's a long game where you
get charged from beginning because you
need it right now and that's fine too
just too much judgement the system right
now on one or the other you know just
that's we've gone unfold judgment tilt
doing it a [ __ ] you want to do I got it
I got it bro I wanted to buy brands one
day when the economy collapsed that's
why I built an agency like I should have
been client services but I have a
strategy
the economy has decided not to collapse
they'll sit in here but you know like
you know but yeah now the machine is
like way greater now I can really
swallow Reebok let alone [ __ ] in you
know so it you know in some ways what I
perceived is like [ __ ] why won't this
they [ __ ] clap well my own thesis on
myself right longer it's gone the more
leverage I have
I used to think that I was gonna fold
Boehner and take the 20% of the team and
work on Aquafina now I won't have to do
that now now somebody else is gonna run
Boehner you know yeah yeah so I'm having
a what I'm calling it maybe that
identity deal problem so I've got my
companies blind zebra yes I get it thank
you and I do doing sales training sales
coaching for myself in Indy for 22 years
I've intentionally wanted to be an
independent just me single shingle
lifestyle biz shut down I'm done good
for you two years ago I'm like you know
what there's no reason not to skip us
good for you tip like I love that story
I think that's one thing that I wish
more people understood yeah you can
change your mind yeah especially I'm the
only guy on the table with
as I think so yet if you okay so I got
it so I got here that here the brands
and I want to get your opinion on okay
if I handed them to you what's the first
good things you think about sales
training sales coaching keynote speaking
I am my wife and I are flying to San
Francisco to launch a wine biz I have
business a PD will meet with John
Wilkinson from the bender bottle amazing
you're gonna say - I didn't see him guys
it's a sports oriented in a can love
words people blind zebra it's gonna be
able to referee calls love it's gonna be
called legal substitution I'm in for
cases can't wait touch it okay your
urine we're doing in the fall macho
thing called hustle fest okay because it
turned into my full hustle and a lot of
guys in the knee carrier bracket Pat
McAfee does the same thing gonna run on
a place do that that's also fast and
I've been doing podcasting for 14 years
I've got 650 episodes in sales it's
called the man selling podcast I've got
a partner in that business got a decent
LinkedIn tribe we've got about 11,000
people in a group and we've got about
5,000 people on email list and I
personally went heavy and LinkedIn early
on and I've got about 11,000 LinkedIn
connections that's might be just my own
personal individual so that's the lay of
the land I'm trying to figure out okay
what end well what would you like to
happen so if I said to you that you know
it's just a business you'd like to do
more revenue so if I just said there's
they're all there separately I get so
friends just reach one so the sales
training thing will be scaled so I've
got this public program called training
camp everything's around football with
the brand and so when I've got training
camp in India you know Emma said so and
so I want we have training camp in
Chicago training camp in Columbus Ohio
how are you gonna do dark
certified coaches like me I've got the
contents already built I just need to go
out and then we're gonna feed leads to
them it's gonna be the stickiness the
while franchise leave I don't want to be
a franchise that complicated something
similar to that
yep speaking I just need an agency to
rep me I just don't do anything to
promote me there's no there's no agency
that wants to rep anybody who hasn't
created the leverage for themselves
first right doesn't exist is there is it
is a is a podcast
thousand Emilie's a month enough
leverage or not got any bigger no it's
not bad but you need to be speaking oh I
am could I do something yeah um do more
yeah yeah and film the [ __ ] out of it
and put it out yeah got it yep yeah the
wine business is a distribution business
we've got to think 80 colleges that are
opening up alcohol sales
you got NFL NHL Major League Baseball
and you go to a tailgater you know
there's no there's no one sport specific
wine and it's in a can so it's single
use and our NFL fan is turn flipping to
female more than male you know how
political that's gonna be to get
distribution right yeah it's really
political here you know the three-tier
system right yeah I've got I came from
Procter gamble yep the only difference
is it's it's actually completely
different than than CPG from the
standpoint of the distributor has the
leverage not the creator of the product
yeah because of the prohibition laws in
place so for you to fort the San
Francisco Giants to serve it at their
you know you know Young's market or
Southern like there's it's an extremely
difficult business I just want to make
sure you go in and wise wide open and
not make too much the first year that's
good Johnson good and this Hustle Fest
is a brandable thing too it's a
conference yeah yes look I mean it's all
this listen you obviously know I mean
you can imagine based on what you just
said how native this question is for me
you know I'm gonna give advice that I
think that I live which is you need to
build up as much personal brand equity
as possible to then funnel into these
energies I believe the way to do that is
to invest in your personal brand
that means produce content and spend
media to amplify it the biggest mistake
people are making right now is they're
relying on organic on their personal
brand because that feels like the right
thing to do there's almost like this
badge of honor of like they get their
traffic from organic it's actually the
reverse it's a super
non-strategic a move to not amplify
media when media is underpriced you
should be spending as much money as you
can afford amplifying your content on
LinkedIn yeah I have a I have a 49%
share in a company called Green Street
out of Los Angeles we've taken some form
of vaynermedia employees that now work
in there it's an agency it's a
conference business called hollow
flowers which we own a piece of and we
own pieces of equity of brands we start
with other individuals who know
exploding as a business model everywhere
yeah so we bought 150 smart cars and
started distribute them all across
California and Nevada and the
interesting thing now that we're up
against is like obviously you can't use
Facebook you can't use it sir yeah but
that's just that sucks for us because we
know it but I keep trying to remember
this is literally my favorite thing
that's going on right now is the
cannabis conversation of like it before
Facebook and answers there were other
thing Oh hundred percent but just go
find those we could also do influencer
marketing yeah like all my cannabis
friends and since I'm really in it and
you know two years ago when I came into
it like there was a legitimacy factor
that the market appreciated and I was
like look like it's it's here's the
punchline everybody I was just had to
cut all the flowers conference every
single person they came up to me and
said Gary what the [ __ ] I can't
Facebook's [ __ ] me I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you they have a term of service
there you don't think they want your
money they're trying to figure it out so
instead of crying about what you can't
do
why aren't you spending all your time
trying to figure out what you can do
like you can start the number one
podcast in the world around cannabis and
dominate this is gonna be great for
cannabis businesses because the drug of
the current unbelievable success of
being sucked into an Instagram Facebook
world is something they're not gonna get
high on which is gonna allow them to
innovate and create something they own
instead of [ __ ] renting
one more closer question for you if you
don't mind so I'm as addicted to
starting new businesses they'll tell you
yes as well so how do you make your
current team feel like you're not gonna
abandon them or is it I'm not abandoning
them by now but it's like look 100
percent will work for me is I would say
things over and over they mainly didn't
believe it and then over time as things
happened they believed it more and
that's how you build a reputation you
know it's it's funny how basic it is but
what do you do like hypnotize them like
no no no because it's still not you
right how do you make sure they know
that you're not gonna band in them that
doesn't come in the form of hiring me
hey I'm here I'm so you know like that
that makes it seem like that you're
going to abandon that has it you know
like here's Carl he's really important
other like [ __ ] this is the fig you know
I've gone the other way huh I've gotten
more in uh you know I'm like literally
like I even eliminated the CEO overall
at Vayner uh I'm the CEO that really
gets you to believe it when the CEOs
operational you know both offices okay
quick photos be on spoon quick selfies
first oh thank you brother president ah
this game [ __ ] amazing bro game Warren
[ __ ] did is amazin unworn hat how they
awesome yeah well thank you
you